Superman is considered by many to be the cultural icon of the United States.
Hi, welcome to WatchMojo.com. I'm your host Derrick Allen...
...and today we'll be exploring this popular character's rich history.
Over the years there has been several reimaginings of Superman...
...and his alter ego Clark Kent.
We have chosen just one of these.
Born on the advanced alien planet Krypton to parents Jor-El and Lara,..
...Superman's birth name is actually Kal-El.
Upon learning of the planet Krypton's impending destruction,..
...a young Kal-El is launched towards Earth by his biological parents.
Shortly after, it is believed that the planet exploded...
...due to a nuclear chain reaction within its core,...
...leaving Kal-El as the last son of Krypton.
Kal-El's spacecraft crashes and is found by Martha and Jonathan Kent in Smallville.
The childless couple adopt the young boy and name him Clark Kent.
It's only during his childhood...
...that both the Kents and Clark himself...
...begin to learn of his out of ordinary abilities.
Super strength, flight and x-ray vision, are just a few of the superhuman powers...
...that a young Clark Kent discovers while growing up.
Encouraged by his adopted parents to use his powers responsibly,...
...Clark chooses to create a secret identity,...
...Superman as his means of fighting crime.
Fearing enemies would discover his true identity and endanger his family and friends,...
...Clark begins working as a reporter in the city of Metropolis...
...and conceals his identity by wearing glasses, changing his hairstyle,...
...as well as altering his voice and body language.